Hello Freak bitches could Joe Rogan.
Hmm
hmm.
Have everything go away.
Your kids are fine.
You have your relationships.
Cool.
Whatever.
Let's take that element out of it.
Let's just take the house,
the cash,
the bows and arrows.
It's all gone.
Could Joe Rogan go live in,
let's just pick New York,
this is not a city question,
but let's pick New York.
Could you go live down by Washington Square Park in a studio,
apartment heavier act.
Have your fans go do your thing and kind of be okay with a low bank account or
have you got,
are you at an age now and you've,
you've had stability.
Do you feel like that would freak you out?
Well it would definitely freak you out if you all the sudden,
like one of the things that I've,
uh,
sort of relied on is not needing anything.
Right?
So by not needing anything,
everything I do,
I do because I enjoy it.
Right?
So like if I do stand up,
I do it cause I enjoy it and if I do podcasts because I enjoy it if I do the UFC
is cause I enjoy it.
I enjoy the money is done.
Don't get me wrong.
Sure.
But I'm not neat.
I'm not needy.
I'm not in a position where I'm like worried about my next check.
I need that stuff.
So if I got to that,
yeah,
not,
not even need that stuff.
Like neither stuff has kind of like if you have a car and you can get around
you,
if you got food on the table and your family's taken care of,
everything else is kind of bullshit.
It's nice.
It's nice to have a good couch.
Like,
look,
we have a 70 inch TV.
Ooh,
this is nice.
Feels Nice.
But Watch Westworld on a 70 inch TV.
It's nice.
Look how big it is.
Woo.
But ultimately what really counts is,
are you nervous?
Are you nervous about your bills?
Cause like,
do you remember that feeling?
Yeah.
That's how terrible feeling.
I never worried about what,
where that's going to come from and what you're going to do.
But you still have your act.
You can still go make money,
but we're going to put you back at square one.
We're going to put you in that studio apartment.
Could you,
could,
would you be cool with it?
I'll studios cost small one.
Oh like a four bedroom house with a yard and some work.
No,
but honestly the,
the big thing,
and this is such a cliche,
but the big thing is do I still have my friends?
Do I still have the same friends?
Because like if I lived in an apartment building and Ari Shaffir lived next door
or any Donkin live down the hallway and Joey was the uh,
over the other side.
Yeah,
I have a great time.
Yeah.
We all lived on the same floor,
the same building.
I would have zero problem with that.
If they knocked on the door.
Hey man,
you got any weed?
I'm going to wait.
Come on.
Exactly.
That would be no problem at all.
It's like how much different is that then when you stay on the road in the
hotel,
right.
Because the hotel is like a studio apartment.
Yeah.
And you're right.
Good percentage of our lives.
We stay in a studio apartment a lot.
I know.
I really,
and I bring it up cause I really,
I was thinking about it and it's like if it all fell apart,
like he grab you grab on to your lifestyle and what you're doing so hard,
but if at all for whatever reason washed away and you could still go perform and
you still had your friends at this club,
he could go see whatever it's,
it's,
I could totally do it.
I could totally go back to I have clothes that fit in this big of a closet and
just,
and just keep doing what I'm doing.
But in those circumstances I 100% in some ways I think your,
you'd be lighter.
You'd be right.
A lot of people do believe that and a lot of people do go towards that
minimalism wife or they give up everything.
My friend Steve Maxwell,
he's a,
a really a world renowned fitness trainer.
Strength and conditioning coach for a lot of pro athletes.
A lot of fighters.
He lives out of a Duffel bag.
Oh,
I saw that guy.
I saw you interviewed guy.
He used to have a big house and he had a gym in Philadelphia,
you'd like one of the very,
he's one of the very first American Brazilian Jiu Jitsu black belts.
And he had his gigantic jam where he's teaching and he said,
you know,
he's an interesting guy.
And then he just decided he got divorced,
right.
And he decided,
you know what,
fuck this.
He goes,
I'm going to live out of a van.
And he got like a,
a camper van and he lived out of that.
And then he's like,
fuck this van I'm getting,
I'm just going to keep traveling now.
He just stays in hotels everywhere.
That's amazing.
And that's what brings it up.
It's the divorce.
I see it.
I don't think,
I don't think willingly I would do it,
but if something was thrust upon me because he got divorced,
divorced or some something,
I would,
uh,
I could go back.
I could be like,
do you,
but you're thinking about it so much that you brought it up as a subject.
It was something you wonder.
Uh,
yeah.
Not as far as the divorce part of it,
but just the simple life.
Yeah.
Because I've built a life that's bigger and more complicated and I,
uh,
you want to know what you want to know what it was.
Last time I was in here,
I had,
um,
I had this back issue where it was like shooting pain down my arm.
Yeah.
You had a cervical issue,
right?
Yeah.
And I was going to,
uh,
this really great Cairo guy.
I was doing cupping,
I was doing all of this kind of stuff and it was just making it worse.
I was just in words.
Yeah.
I was in,
I was in pain for like a year.
I was like in pain.
Greg row Gal,
you know,
the comedian Greggor Gal,
he tells me he had really developed debilitating lower back pain and he read
[inaudible] book.
Yeah.
I read,
sorry.
He's like,
just read it.
And I got it.
This big fight with him in the sun and uh,
and uh,
know him who owns the comedy cellar.
He's calling him a crack and it's a crackpot and it doesn't work and all this
stuff.
And Greg is like,
just please read it.
Just read it,
just read it and it's,
you know what it is.
It's just basically about that you're carrying,
your brain wants to go to work on something simple like pain in your body rather
than deal with issues of stress and anxiety and anger that you carry all the
time and basically just realizing that that's where the pain is coming from.
Don't have to solve the anxiety or the pain or the anger.
You just have to be aware,
okay brain,
I know what you're doing,
I know what you're working on.
It just kind of alleviates that stress.
And then the physical manifestation of not having oxygen go into your,
into your muscles and stuff starts to slowly release and just it,
it's gone.
It's gone.
It's,
I have no pain.
I have no,
how long did it take after you read the book and adopted the principles?
I go month and a half.
Really?
Yeah.
So a year of pain and then a month and a half of adopting these principles and
like what does he tell you to do?
Like,
what are the exercises that he tells you to do?
He says,
just live.
Don't just a live your life,
exercise,
whatever you were doing,
do it.
Don't live timidly don't think I can't run now.
I can't do yoga now because I've got a neck issue.
Do it live your life.
Don't live like in this preventative way of I can't move or I'm going to mess up
my,
my body.
So what does he tell you about like physical issues?
Like what if you have a herniated disc and it's pressing against your nerve and
it's causing your hands to go numb and your arms atrophying.
He says there's,
those are very rare cases.
It's not that rare in my world.
I know.
Well yeah,
you're right.
But he says,
he says it's very rare cases where there's like a real pinched nerve kind of a
problem.
A lot seems like crazy advice.
I know a lot of people that have like real issues,
like real physical issues.
It's not a rare thing I don't think to have like disc issues are gigantic.
Yeah.
It's cause people,
they don't strengthen their spine enough.
They don't drink their core enough and they wind up doing something to Yank it
and they heard it and then they try to work around it and they wind up
reactivating it and then it gets worse and worse.
He was saying that the,
a lot of times you'll have,
um,
you'll have like your disk will be bulging a little bit or whatever these little
imperfections are and we all have these imperfections in us,
but when you are stressed and the muscles are tightening around you and becoming
inflamed because you're carrying this stuff that you're not working through,
everything's constricting around it.
So then it's going to aggravate that and that's going to become a bigger
problem.
I definitely think that's true.
Um,
and some cases,
but there's like,
there's legitimate,
like I had a conversation with a friend of mine about this with the same sort of
a thing and I was like that.
That's all well and good,
but I know people who were very light and happy people who develop a legitimate
back issue and has nothing to do with stress that they're carrying around and
has to do with the soft tissue that protects your joints,
bulging out and contacting a nerve.
Look,
there's a zillion of us out there and I'm sure there's all different issues for
it,
but back to your original question of why am I thinking about simplifying and
all this kind of stuff?
I am a pretty light,
positive person,
very optimistic,
very.
I kind of live in that world,
but when I just started reading the book I'm like,
I think is really pissing me off.
Am I stressed?
Do I have anxiety because I live in this house because I'm trying to do these
things with my career because I'm trying to always do this because I'm carrying
children and parents and all of this stuff.
I'm trying to make everybody happy.
I'm just,
I don't know.
Maybe just realizing that in thinking about it,
I'm in no heavy meditation on it.
No.
Just being aware that maybe that's where it's coming from.
I'm telling you over a month and a half,
the pain slowly went away and I don't have it.
Yeah,
that is interesting.
So what,
like what was bothering you before?
Like I know that you're,
you know,
you're successful and you had a television show for a while and you've got a
bunch of projects going on.
You're always doing standup and specials,
so you've had a lot of success,
you've got a lot of great stuff going on.
What was,
what was kind of chewing at you?
I don't know.
I'm not really 100% sure of what the sources,
but I do feel like I have a lot of people on my back and it's all,
it's all quiet.
It's all in my head,
you know what I mean?
A lot of people on your back.
Yeah,
I've got a wife,
I've got,
I've got kids,
I've got pets,
I've got family.
I've got
in the in that you feel that there's a weird,
weird way to bring this,
bring this up.
But is that,
how much of that,
like having a wife and having kids,
obviously there's going to be compromises and there's going to be stressed that
comes along with any sort of relationship,
but do you feel like it was tipping more towards the negative than towards the
positive?
Um,
I don't think it was.
I think I just,
uh,
the whole experience to me seems positive.
My relationship with my wife is great.
The kids I adore.
I feel like it's all positive,
but I do carry the burden of everybody's worries and everybody's wellbeing all
the time.
I was working on this axis,
this joke in my act before I started thinking about all this stuff I had this
moment when I was standing in this house,
I moved to this bigger house.
It's a really nice house.
It's a bigger how bigger home.
And I was shutting off all the lights is what I was working through on stage.
I was turning off all the lights one night and locking the doors for all the bad
people that are coming to get us.
And everyone's in their beds and the cat's asleep and the dog's asleep and
everybody the lizard to sleep.
And it just,
all my responsibility washed over me like everybody,
every living thing here is,
is uh,
depending on my success,
if I don't keep going,
if I don't keep succeeding this,
everything here changes everybody's little life.
Everybody's Pref,
perfect little existence.
It's all washing over me and I can't tell anyone about it.
I could tell you the audience,
but I can't go sit on my daughter's bed at two in the morning when I have that
feeling.
Honey,
you ever,
do you ever feel like you just can't do it anymore?
You ever feel like he can't,
he just want to stop.
He just want to take a break.
This whole thing about waking up my daughter with my fears,
I can't do that.
I don't tell my wife that stuff.
I don't tell my kids that stuff.
I just carry it.
So when I started reading this book,
I'm like,
maybe I'm just taking all this really seriously and feeling like,
hmm.
Did you
extended with the new home?
Is that it?
Cause a lot of times I have a friend of mine,
I did that recently.
He bought a big place and uh,
he can afford it,
but kind of right.
You know,
it's like,
okay,
think about this now I'm a,
I'm a big advocate in never doing that.
Yeah.
I don't think you should ever buy a big place unless you're like,
hey,
we can get a nice place now and not even think about it.
Let's,
no,
we're totally cool.
We can do it.
And it's,
you know,
I hadn't really small place for a long time and did all the right thing.
So it's,
the outlay is no different from my little place before.
It's all cool.
But when you walk into a place like that,
it just feels bigger.
It just,
you know,
the first time I bought a home ever,
I had this little place in studio city.
It's a little,
you know,
I just,
I remember laying on the couch like,
hi,
I don't know if I can take with this.
I've got to sign this paper.
And towards the years is a long,
every time the mail came for the first year that I owned home,
I thought it was going to be a notice saying you've got to get out of there now.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
I just was fearful about it.
Mortgages are weird,
man.
It's like you here's a bill for 30 years,
right?
Yeah.
That's heavy.
That weighs on you.
Yeah.
So that's what it just brought me to the feeling of like,
well maybe just going back and living with my wife in that little studio
apartment in New York again,
wouldn't be so bad.
Kid's a freak out.
It'd be the kids would free kids would hate it.
The kids would have to be gone.
Fuck this dad.
You need to be more successful.
Yeah.
Just take your pressure like a man ditch.
Why did you downsize?
Who cares if your next crooked son of a bitch,
who cares if your arms go numb?
I want to go to Berkeley.
Everything's with your teeth.
So I don't know.
I mean,
cause it's a,
it was a little self aware moment because I do,
like I said,
um,
I feel like I'm pretty carefree,
but why the hell was my neck so
[inaudible]
okay.